yesterday the st louis fed they
published a brand new article and it
absolutely blew my mind they literally
are pricing goods using bitcoin as a
unit of account i'm not kidding as we
can see what they were trying to
identify is that the fed wanted to show
currency-related price volatility but of
course the bitcoiners they've been
talking about this forever if you have
an asset like the us dollar where the
supply continues to be manipulated it's
really hard to measure price increases
or decreases because the denominator is
moving as well bitcoin's a fixed supply
asset and so naturally it serves as a
much better way to measure are goods and
their prices going up or are they going
down now the fed they're simply writing
this as a troll they think it's
hilarious they want to actually show
that bitcoin's volatile but what they
don't realize is that bitcoin is living
rent free in their head now all of a
sudden we have central bankers and we
have research analysts all starting to
think about the idea of pricing various
goods and services in bitcoin if bitcoin
becomes a unit of account sure right now
it's a joke but as they say first they
laugh at you then they fight you and
then you win
seeing the st louis fed published this
yesterday was a seminal moment all of a
sudden they're recognizing that bitcoin
it's real bitcoin is something they're
talking about internally and yes they
may not take it seriously today but
eventually they'll realize that the
digital sound money is a much better
unit of account for measuring things
like currency related price volatility
hey you did you like this video great we
make five of them a day and post them
here on this channel make sure you
subscribe like the video and see you
next time